دعت منظمه العفو الدوريه الرئيسه التونسي
قيس سعيد الى وقف ما وصفته باعتدائه على
الحق في محاكمه عادله والكف عن محاكمه
مدنيين امام المحاكم العسكريه وتشهد تونس
في الاونه الاخيره تصاعدا لايقافات شملت
سياسيين معارضين وشخصيات قضائيه واعلاميه
ووزراء سابقين وهو ما اعتبرته المعارضه
دليلا عمليا على الطبيعه الديكتاتوريه
لحكم سعيد
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلالات موجه
الايقافات المتصاعده في تونس بحق معارضين
سياسيين وشخصيات قضائيه واخرى اعلاميه
وتوجيه اتهامات لهم بالتامر على الدوله
والانتماء لتنظيم ارهابي كيف تبدو خطه
رئيس قيس سعيد لمعالجه الازمه السياسيه في
بلاده وللتعامل مع المعرضين السياسيين في
الوقت الذي يتهمه خصومه بالدكتاتوريه
والانتهاك الصارخ للقوانين ولحقوق الانسان
ما هي استراتيجيه المعارضه في المرحله
المقبله مع اتساع رقعه الايقافات بحق
رموزها وهل ستمضي في اتجاه طرح مبادره
لتوحيد صفوفها والخروج بالبلاد من ازمتها
وما السبيل الى تفعيل لغه الحوار بين
الاطراف للخروج من عنق الزجاجه
[موسيقى]
من لم تطله الايقافات بعد بين رموز
المعارضه لسياسه الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد
واتباعهم سؤال تطرحه المعارضه التونسيه
وهي توثق ما تصفه بحمله ايقافات متصاعده
لشخصيات سياسيه معارضه اضافه الى اخرى
اعلاميه وقضائيه ومن عالم الاعمال من قبل
فرق امنيه تقول المعارضه انها ترتع في طول
البلاد وعرضها بعيدا في اغلب الاحوال عن
اي تقيد بالقوانين والاجراءات تحت غطاء
تنفيذ التعليمات القادمه من مستويات اعلى
في هرم سلطه ما بعد الخامس والعشرين من
يوليو في المقابل لا يتوقف الرئيس سعيد عن
مهاجمه معارضيه واصفا اياهم بالخونه
والفاسدين والعملاء للخارج متمسكا بما
يقول انه تطبيق للقانون على الجميع متوجها
للقضاه بالقول ان من يتجرا على تبرئتهم
سيكون شريكا لهم في جرائمهم
[موسيقى]
ارحب بضيفينا لمناقشه الموضوع منسوسه شرقي
تونس السيد قيصر الصياح المحامي والباحث
في القانون ومن تونس العاصمه رضا بلحاج
القيادي في جبهه الخلاص الوطني مرحبا بكما
سيد رضا بالحاج انتم في الجبهه ما تقييمكم
لخلفيات هذه التوقيفات خاصه الاخيره التي
طالت السيد الشابي
واضح انه بعد الفشل الذي حققه قيس سعيد في
مختلف محطات خريطه الطريق التي رسمها سواء
الاستفتاء سواء الدوره الاولى من
الانتخابات او الدوره الثانيه والمقاطعه
الشعبيه العارمه لهذه الاستحقاقات يريد
تلهيه
وتوجيه الراي العام لوجهه اخرى فانطلق في
اعتقالات وايقافات وفبركه ملف
يتعلق بالتامر على امن الدوله
ويتعلق بمناضلين ديمقراطيين عرفوا منذ
عقود بسلميه تحركهم بنظالاتهم وتضحياتهم
على غرار
على غرار عصام الشابي على غرار خيام
التركي على غرار
بقيه الموقوفين في هذه الفتره مثل المحامي
الازهر العكرمي ووقع توجيه تهم كثيره بعد
مداهمه منازلهم وبعد ايقافهم في الشارع او
في محلات سكناهم بدون اذن قضائي في اغلبهم
او تكوين اذن قضائي بعد ايقافهم ب 48 ساعه
اليوم يقبعون في السجن وفي غرف ايقاف
تفتقر لابسط الشروط الانسانيه
ويخضعون لقانون الارهاب الذي فيه العديد
من المضايقات مثل منع المحامين من الاتصال
بمناوبيهم 48 ساعه منه كذلك ان يبقوا في
احتفاظ مده 15 يوم وهي عمليه تنكيل وتفريغ
للحياه السياسيه وترهيب السياسيين بعد
تنامي المعارضه واتساعها
بعد الفشل في الاستحقاقات كما قلت والازمه
الاقتصاديه الخانقه والازمه الماليه
العموميه والعجز عن الاستجابه
قيصر الصياح قيصر المواطن الاساسيه كمحامي
وباحث في القانون هل هذه
التوقيفات والمداهمات والتفتيشات للمنازل
وقطع الطريق بسيارات امنيه
واعتقال مثل ما حدث مع سيده شيماء عيسى
واقيادها الى مكان مجهول هل هذه اجراءات
قانونيه بتقديرك
شكرا مساء الخير اولا
المواثيق الدوليه والصكوك والمعاهدات
الدوليه كلها والدستور التونسي نفسه في
ماده 33 تضمن حقوق كل طرف محقق معادله
شفافه امام قضاها النزيه ومحايد ثانيا ان
سياده الدول تقاس بمدى قدرته على تطبيق
قانونها والقانون هو السلطان والفيصل
بموجب الادوات التي يقويلها
هل هذه هل هذه الاعتقالات قانونيه بحسب
القانون التونسي
بحسب القانون التونسي والدستور التونسي لا
اقول الاعتقالات قانونيه ام غير قانونيه
لان هذه الاعتقالات يجب ان تكون في اطار
المحاكمه العادله امام قضاء المحايد كما
ينص ذلك الدستور التونسي وفي اطار
الاجراءات واحترام كل المواثيق التي تجبر
الدوله التونسيه على احترام حقوق مواطنيها
في محاكمه عادله اما ان نتحول الى البحث
عن الاخلالات او او الاشياء يعني التي قد
تكون اضرت ببعض الحقوق في اطار الدفاع او
في اطار يعني القيام بعمليات المداهمه او
التفتيش او الحجز فتلك من المسؤولات
السلطه القضائيه وحدها باعتبارها سلطه
مستقله ولا كامل الصلاحيه والذي قام بهذه
التتبعات ليس رئيس الجمهوريه رئيس
الجمهوريه هو المسؤول عن الامن القومي وهو
رئيس المجلس الامن القومي بالبلاد لكن
رئيس الجمهوريه ليس نيابه عموميه نيابه
العموميه هي الوحيده التي يقفل لها
القانون بالماده عشرين وبموجبه الفقيه
الامم المتحده عدد 22 على اربعين المؤرخه
سنه 1990 لتقوموا بواجباتها بكل الدول
لملاحقه لا يشبهات والتطرق الملفات التي
قد تشوبها عيوب اما ان ننتقل الى توظيف
سياسي بحث صرف
ونمزجه بالطبع القانوني هذا امر يعني خارج
عن المنطق وخارج
عنكم
النيابه العموميه يعني تعمل خارج اطار
واوامر الرئيس قيس سعيد بالتالي بحسب ما
يقول السيد قيصر الصياح الرئيس سعيد لا
يستخدم
القضاء في في السياسه بل هي امور منفصله
يعني لا علاقه بمعارضه هؤلاء الذين يتم
اعتقالهم معنى يجري والاعتقال على اساسه
ما ردك
ما يحدث اليوم بالنسبه للقضاء اليوم
القضاء خاضع بطريقه مباشره
لقيس سعيد ولوزيره العدل بعد حل المجلس
الاعلى للقضاء وعزل القضاه اليوم ليست
هنالك نيابه في تونس وكيل جمهوريه تونس
ليس بعد عزل وكيل الجمهوريه الشرعي الذي
تم تسميته بمقتضى المجلس الاعلى للقضاء
المنتخب لم قيس سعيد لم يسمي في هذه
الوظيفه وكيل جمهوريه هنالك اليوم وكاله
جمهوريه تخدع مباشره لوزيره العدل ولقيس
سعيد
القضاء اليوم في وضع يخضع لضغوطات كبيره
وينفذ
التعليمات والتوجهات التي ترسمها السلطه
التنفيذيه وعلى راسها قيس سعيد وما تصريحه
البارحه
على على من ان القاضي الذي لا يدين هؤلاء
الموقوفين هو مشارك في الجريمه هو بمثابه
قول بان لا يوجد قضاء والقاضي هو قيس سعيد
ومن يخالف قيس سعيد فهو معرض للعقوبات
فالحديث اليوم على قضاء مستقل وعلى معايير
دوليه
لمحاكمه عادله هو كلام لا اساس له من
الصحه وبعيد عن الواقع الذي نعيشه يوميا
في ظل تفكيك السلطه القضائيه واعتبارها
وظيفه بين ايدي الرئيس الجمهوريه طيب سيد
قيصر اذا كان القضاء مستقل كما تفضلت كيف
يستقيم اعتقال عز الدين الحسقي والد جوهر
بن مبارك بعد ان تم
مداهمه منزل بن مبارك ومحاصرته
ولم يكن موجودا في المنزل فتم اعتقال
والده كيف يستقيم هذا مع الصوره والنظره
الاخلاقيه التي يقدم نفسه الرئيس قيس سعيد
بها الى التونسيين
انا قلت ان جمهوريه لا علاقه له بالقضاء
القضاء مرفق مستقل بذاته وهو في نفس الوقت
مستقل له صلاحيه وهو مرفق عدله انه طبق
العداله في تونس وان ننفذ القانون ونقوم
بانفاذ القانون بحذافيره اما ان نقوم
بتوظيف سياسي لكل ظاهره معينه تسلط فيها
يعني
قمع او تسلط فيها اخلال ببعض الاجراءات
فهذا امر لا يستقيم انا اقول لك ان هناك
سته ولكن معروف
ان السيد جوهر بن مبارك هو معارض لسياسات
الرئيس بالتالي لم تستطع القوى الامنيه
القاء القبض عليه فالقت القبض على والدي
هكذا هو الحال في تونس الان
هكذا وواقع القضاء
ليس هذا الحل في تونس بدليل ان اشرس
المعارضين للرئيس قيس سعيد الان متواجدون
بشرحيب ومتواجدون بكافه انحاء العاصمه مثل
السيده عبير موسى ويطالبون بحقوق معينه في
اطار الديمقراطيه التمثيليه ويهاجمون
احيانا حتى رئيس الجمهوريه القائد الاعلى
للقوات المسلحه ورمز الدوله التونسيه ولم
يحرك ساكنا رئيس ولم يقوم القضاء حتى
بتتبعهم في طرد ديمقراطيه فكيف لنا ان
نمزج بعض القيادات الشرسه التي تهاجم
الرئيس ويطاليا الان وحره بين الاخرين
الذين تم اعتقالهم واعيد القول مره ثانيه
ان المتهم بريء الى ان تثبت بموجب الماده
سبعه ثمانيه يحتاج من القرارات الامم
المتحده
الدول العربيه التي ابرمت في تونس اطار
حقوق الانسان ولكن اعتقال السيد رضا اعتقد
مثال بان الرئيس سعيد قال بان القضاه
الذين سيبرئون هؤلاء فهم ايضا متهمون هذا
يعني
حكم مبرم
ليس صحيح لان الرئيس لو حتى نعود الى
تصريحات الرئيس يجب ان نكون هكذا يعني في
اطار
التوصيف العام الرئيس قال كل من هؤلاء لم
يذكر كلمه قضاء اصلا والرئيس يعني
من يبرئ فهو ايضا مدان
الشخص الذي يبرئ الوحيد هو القضاء لكن
الرئيس تحدث عن منظور سياسي اخر موضوع
هناك سياسيه يعني تحت الطاولات هناك الان
جبل كبير وحلبه كبيره بين الراي والراي
المضاد والاستنزاف والاستنزاف في المضاد
سواء تصريحات ناتي الجهه او ذاك لكن رئيس
دوله يبقى من كل الحالات لانه تحدث بصفه
عامه عن بعض الوسائل الاعلاميه التي تبرئ
قبل حتى المحاكمه الاشخاص وتعطي اوصافا
وتكييفا لتلك الجرائم التي هي وصفت الان
من طرف النيابه العموميه الجالسه راى
الدوله والبعض فيها جرائم اخر يتعلق
بتكوين وفاق والبعض الاخر يتعلق بتبيض
الاموال فكيف نحن خارج هذا الاطار انغمس
داخل اعمال تقوم بها الفراق المركزيه
بالعوامل الان وفرق القوميه لمقاومه
الهجره وفرق مكافحه
فقط في اطار قطب قضائي وبستقل اسمه القطب
القضائي المالي والاداري ومكافحه
القضاء قال الرئيس انا وظيفه وليس القدر
فقط الرئيس تحدث فيه مره عن نفسه قال انا
موظف لدى الدوله سلطه تنفيذيه والقضاء له
استقلاليه بموجب قانوني الداخلي الاساسي
لسنه 1967 حتى مادته العشرين تعطيه يعني
الى الان هذا القانون الثاني المفعول
تعطيه كل الصلاحيه ليكون قضاء مستقلا وحتى
عندما نعود الى الدستور نجد ان القضاء
التونسي في الدستور الحالي يعني الدستور
سنه 2022 وهو قضاء مستقل فكيف لنا ان نتبع
بعض المصطلحات من هذا المكان للقول بان
القضاء وظيفه والجزائر نفسها الدوله
الشقيقه كانت منذ ثلاث او اربع سنوات الى
الوراء تعتبر القضاء وظيفه ثم ارجعته قضاء
مستقلا ثم اردت فقط ان اعرج على شيء مهم
جدا
اخذنا وقت طويل اريد ان اسمع راي السيد
رضا بالحاج في قضيه سيد رضا من القضايا
التي تحظى باهتمام داخلي ملف
القاضي البشير العكرمي ما هي الجوانب التي
تلف هذا هذا الملف وما الذي يخشى من هذا
القاضي بالتالي تم تهميشه وحتى تعرض
للكثير من الضغوطات ما الذي نعرفه عن هذه
القضيه كمثال في يعني سياق الايقافات
وابعاد بعض الشخصيات عن
المراكز القضائيه
هو مثله مثل بقيه الموقوفين هو تعرض
لعمليه طرد وعزل من القضاء ثم تحصل على
احكام من المحكمه الاداريه بالرجوع الى
وظيفته في الاثناء ومع الحمله الحمله
الاعتقالات وقعت مداهمه منزله منذ عشره
ايام واعتقانه
وتفتيش منزله واحالته على قاضي تحقيق
والنيابه العموميه التي اذنت باطلاق سراحه
لان الملف الذي قدم لا يتوفر فيه شروط
الادانه او الابقاء بحاله ايقاف مما جعل
القاضي يترك سبيله عند تسريحه وقع ايقافه
من طرف اعوان الامن واقتياده الى مستشفى
الامراض العقليه وايوائه بطريقه وجوبيه
بقرار من المحكمه عندها وقعت العديد من
التنديدات بهذه الممارسه وفي الاول وقع
رفض للهيئه مقاومه التعذيب بان تزوره ثم
تمكنت من زيارته ومعاينه حالته هذا
الايواء في المستشفى
يحوم حوله العديد من الغموض ويمكن ان يفسر
ابعاد القاضي العكرمي عن
من الاتصال بمحاميه وبان يصرح
تنصت خارجها خارج السياق القانون على كل
حال تصاعد موجه الايقافات في تونس اثار
عددا من ردود الفعل الدوليه التي سرعان ما
رد عليها الرئيس التونسي رافضا ما يعتبره
تدخل خارجيا يمس السياده التونسيه قيس
سعيد كان يشير بهذا الموقف بمتابعين
لاعراب المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه بل
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
نيد برايس واشار الى قلق الولايات المتحده
الشديد ازاء تقارير عن اعتقال شخصيات
سياسيه ورجال اعمال وصحفيين في تونس
والاتحاد الاوروبي قال انه يتابع بقلق
التطورات الاخيره في تونس التي وصفها
بالجاره القريبه جدا والتي ترتبط مع
الاتحاد بعلاقات استراتيجيه وعميقه وكانت
مفوضيه الامم المتحده الساميه لحقوق
الانسان قد طالبت هي الاخرى بالافراج
الفوري عن المعتقلين في في بلد يعاني اصلا
من ازمه اقتصاديه وماليه خانقه خانقه عفوا
سيد قيصر صياح اذا منظمه الدوليه دعت
الرئيس اذا الكف عن محاكمه المدنيين امام
المحاكم العسكريه ايضا كمحامي اسالك لماذا
يلجا الرئيس السعيد لمحاكمه مدنيين امام
القضاء العسكري
انا عاوز اقول مره ثانيه وثالثه وقلت هذا
حتى في قناه الجزيره عديد المرات قلت ان
الامر لا يجب اخذه بهذا الشكل ولان ان ان
سوق الامور بهذه الطريقه خاصه من وجهه نظر
الطيف المعارض نحن ضد المحاكمه الغاشمه
ونحن مع براءه كل متهم الى ان تثبت في
محاكمه عازه طبق القوانين وسكوك الدوليه
لكن لا للتوظيف السياسي للقانون طب لماذا
لا تكون امامكم مدنيه لماذا لا تكون
امامها حكم مدنيه
نعم عندما استمع الى تصريحات منظمه العفو
الدوليه فانا استمع كذلك الى تصريحات
السيد ماركوس كارنارو سفير الاتحاد
الاوروبي الذي قال نحن الان نتقاسم ورئيس
الدوله والجمهوريه التونسيه نفس القيم
والحقوق واعود الى بربر الخارجيه
الامريكيه
قال نحن الان منذ ثلاثه او اربعه اسابيع
اتجاه لم اختم السيد رضا لماذا لا تكون
هذه المحاكمات امام محاكم مدنيه باقتضاب
هو هذا مطلبنا لا عفوا قيصر عفوا السيد
قيصر اريد ان اسمع منك قبل ان ننتقل للسيد
رضا بالحاج لماذا لا تكون امام محاكم
مدنيه باقتضاض
لان ما زلت المرافعات العسكريه الى حد
تتضمن قوانين واضحه وصريحه تحيل في بعض
الوضعيات وفي بعض التكييفات القانونيه
اشخاصا المدنيين على المحكمه العسكريه
لتلقيحه خلال فتره حكم المعارضه خلاص وضحت
الرئيس قيس
سيد رضا اذا كان الهدف من الاعتقالات هو
يعني التستر على
المشروع كما تسمونه الفاشل للرئيس قيس
سعيد لاسيما الاقتصادي والسياسي اذا ما هي
خيارات المعارضه الان وباتت الاعتقالات
تطال شخصيات سياسيه بارزه وانا مستقبل
المبادره التي تستعد المعارضه لطرحها في
هذا السياق
هو الهدف كذلك كما قلت في بدايه هذا
الحديث ان قيس سعيد
استهدف المعارضه لانه علم بان هنالك مشروع
لتوحيد المعارضه هنالك حوارات
لتوحيد المعارضه لمقاومه الانقلاب هنالك
مبادره الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل التي
تهدف للعوده للديمقراطيه والعوده لدستور
2014 مع تنقيحه وتنقيح المجله الانتخابيه
والتركيز حكومه انقاذ وطني وبالتالي قيس
سعيد امام هذا الاتساع للمعارضه وتقاربها
خصوصا الشخصيات التي تسعى لتقريب المعارضه
مثل عصام الشابي التركي وغيرهم عمد الى
هذه العمليه امتعل امتاع الاعتقالات
العشوائيه وبالتالي اليوم المعارضه تتسع
مطالبها تقترب من بعضها والاتحاد
كمبادر لحلحله الوضع هو اليوم محل استهداف
كذلك من قيس سعيد نراه يستهدف نقابيين
هنالك تتبعات قضائيه ضد نقابيين وطرد شكرا
خطه قيس سعيد شكرا رضا بالحاج في تونس
وقيصر الصياح في سوسه شكرا لكم احمد
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر شكرا لمتابعه الى اللقاء بامان
الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]